dan how was it for you to get your first
job as a script reader and if you can
paint a little bit about your life at
that time
well I gotten out of NYU film and I
definitely was interested in
screenwriting that was kind of my focus
coming out of film school and I really
wanted to get into script reading and I
had been interning at the Tribeca Film
Center in New York for a company that
was co-owned by Robert De Niro's
production company and in the same
building was Miramax Films and so I I
just kind of got to know some people
there and it was funny my first reading
job for them it was their genre division
called Dimension Films and I remember
calling up the supervisor there or no
I'm sorry I remember getting a referral
to them but the guy said they're not
hiring now don't bother calling them and
because I was you know I had a lot of
initiative I called anyway and the first
thing the supervisor told me when he
picked up the phone was oh we have a
reader job open do you want to test for
it and so I did a test coverage which is
they give you a script that they've
already had coverage on and so I did
coverage on it so then they evaluate
they evaluate you on that coverage
because they already know the script
really well and so that's how I got
working for them and then I transferred
over to the Miramax division which was
their parent company and I had I had
also been freelancing for a number of
other companies in New York City other
production companies and studios so when
you came to New York to go to NYU do you
remember like some of the scripts in
your mind that you thought this is the
sort of the genre I want to write in
this is what I want to create well I'd
been it was funny because the growing up
I was really kind of more into I guess
like Spielberg stuff or kind of more
action stuff like Rambo and that kind of
stuff but then before I went to NYU I
transferred in as a junior I started
getting into Scorsese and I was
you know taxi driver and that kind of
stuff and Goodfellas and Oliver Stone
and I knew that Scorsese and Oliver
Stone and Spike Lee had gone to NYU so I
really wanted to go there so I applied
and I got in just on the wait list and
then they had called really late in the
summer before my junior year and said we
have an opening on the waitlist so
that's why I went to NYU that's how I
was able to get in and it was just
really cool to be in New York where
these filmmakers that I really admired
had gone you know
so yeah Scorsese Oliver Stone Spike Lee
the Coen brothers and these were all
filmmakers that I really you know wanted
to emulate so going back to what your
jobs were what your tasks were so you
finally get in here you were told sorry
I don't even bother you give it a shot
anyway it turns out as luck would have
it they do have a slot do you remember
what your first few weeks were as the
script reader and well I remember
because I got I got scripts and books
because I was in New York and that was
the literary capitals so I would read a
lot of books ahead of publication they
the agents and book editors would send a
book out to the studios to see if any
studios or production companies wanted
to option the movie rights and so I
would be the first reader at the
production company or studio to read
that unpublished galley version and that
was hard to do because a lot of times
they would literally give you a 600 page
book to read overnight and I had to
write up a three to five page report
about it by you know noon the next day
and that was hard to do I actually got I
got let go from one of my jobs early on
because I just I just couldn't turn over
the material that fast and so I had to
kind of learn on the job trial by fire
and just learned to read really fast and
to intuit that structure that movie
structure
and as I'm reading this book I'm asking
myself will this transfer over to a
movie you know does it have that
potential for that 3/4 act structure
that 95% of great movies use and so it
was all about structure there wasn't
also dialogue things yeah no it was it
was evaluating the whole thing as a
reader I was evaluating the whole script
structured dialogue you know character
development all that stuff but if you're
reading something like a novel or a
graphic novel or even like a piece from
The New Yorker or Rolling Stone or you
know any kind of article that they're
interested in making a movie of you have
to evaluate it as a potential movie so
you're asking yourself does it have the
three or four act structure of a
commercial film so that's interesting so
it sounds actually fairly intimidating
because I know I've been in situations
like that where no one really tells you
what the rules are you kind of have to
as you said into it or watch other
people so how was that where were people
actually giving you tips on how to do
with all that or no you kind of had to
every man for himself not a whole lot
you didn't get a whole lot of feedback
when I was first starting out maybe a
few supervisors might have given me a
few little tips about coverage but after
a while they don't really give you any
feedback you don't even know where this
script goes after you send in your
coverage report so I would really have
to ask afterward like hey that that
script that I really loved that anything
happened with it and so they might tell
me oh we didn't buy it but Fox bought it
or something like that but as a reader
you you're not told anything so you have
to inquire you have to have the
initiative to see what happens after
that and you're not a part of the
process of development or purchasing it
or bidding on it or anything like that
after you read it once maybe twice it's
out of your hands and then your
supervisors the coordinators the execs
the VP's they're the ones who are going
to be deciding whether the company is
going to option it or
and that's fascinating I wonder where
there are certain scripts that you would
read just the first 10 pages of and you
just knew right away this was not gonna
go anywhere and if yeah why I mean as
crazy as it sounds it could be the first
paragraph it could be the first line I
mean if there's two typos in the first
line like it's probably not gonna go
anywhere you know it's very rare
incredibly rare that the first 10 20 30
pages will be weak and then the script
gets a whole lot better later you know
if a writer doesn't know how to write a
great act 1 they're not going to learn
later or suddenly turn it around and
have a great act 2a or act to be
you